hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the penultimate
round of the 2019 World Team
Championship for some reason in my
previous video I said that Dingley Rijn
was missing for the past few days that
he was relaxing for the for the final
round but for some reason I missed that
he actually played in the previous round
and against none other than Michael
Adams so it's an excellent match up I'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it it's a lovely
game
dinkler and currently number three
player in the world the only other
member of the 2800 club alongside Carson
and Caruana
ina giver is very close I think three
points below 2800 but yeah definitely
the highest rated player in this
tournament and well most likely the
strongest he faces Michael Adams
legendary English Grandmaster who some
20 years ago was ranked number four in
the world but still a very strong
Grandmaster of course playing board one
for England let's let's check out the
game you know I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy it and sorry about no Greek photo
yesterday especially since it was a
Grisha game but you know for that reason
we do have an excellent photo of today
so here it is I hope you enjoyed there
we have it Sasha looking excellent as
always and it seems it seems the Grisha
found out that we are showing some
excellent photos of him on this channel
and he decided to suit up for the
occasion that that of course was a joke
this is a photo from the opening
ceremony so everyone was addressed very
nicely but there we have it so without
further ado dink has the white pieces
and he opens with Knight to f3 and
before we check out the game I here is a
bonus question for you who can remember
the last time dinkler and actually lost
the game so there you have it you know
just think about it
and if you know you know do share in the
comments but okay we have B 5 the reti
opening is on the board we have g3 the
Kings Indian attack
Knight to f6 and we have just brush up
the g2 developing we have c5 since dink
is using the the hyper modern approach
to the development you know controlling
the central with the pieces
Michael Adams goes for the principle
approach and he takes the central
with his pawns we have castles g 6d for
biding c captures knight characters and
Bishop to g7 we have Knight to b3
castles by Adams and knife to c3 now by
dink with east six placing the the pawns
on light squares as you do have a dark
square bishop so this is very you know
nicely working together we have E for
biding deciding whether you want to
capture here you're not able to push d4
as the Queen both Queen and Knight are
controlling d4 so here we have Knight to
c6 by Adams
d captures on e4 was played in a game in
2014 Demetria Cove incorporated against
Sergey Kerrigan but Kerrigan was able to
win that game with the white pieces so
here Knight to c6 and now just eke a
trace on d5 and here it captures on d5
was played in 1979 Soviet championship
Michael Tao played Knight captures on d5
but he in the end he lost that game
against her Oleg Roman Inchon so here he
captures on d5 and now just Bishop to g5
pinning that night preparing Queen to d2
maybe you will want to challenge blacks
dark square bishop here you want to
connect rooks get the D rooks into the
game so here we have east with h6 just
you know asking a white what do you want
to do with the bishop Bishop to e6 is
another known move here as the the d5
pawn is already attacked three times by
Knight Queen and Bishop so you do want
to maybe defend it
this move has been attempted before but
now we have h6 this is a new move so it
seems Adams prepared something for ding
Lyra and let's see how Dean deals with
it
so of course you don't want to capture I
mean you don't want to leave yourself
Bishop less against blacks very strong
dark square bishop so Bishop backed up
III and now rook to e8 and we have Queen
to d2 black played h6 so he created a
target you do want to develop well also
are you know making black deal with the
weakness so you could go King to h7 it
is a possibility but here black finds an
active plan Knight to g4 he defends h6
while also attacking the e3 bishop and
you know you definitely wouldn't mind
grabbing this dark square bishop so ding
doesn't allow it we have
the c5 and now it's very interesting
what if you play b6 here if you play b6
here you're really annoying this this
dark square bishop but after Bishop a3
a3 is actually a very nice square for
the bishop not only do you control this
very nice diagonal you also control the
b2 pawn which could come under attack
from this bishop but then even after
Knight to f6 you're gonna lose this bond
for example Knight captures Knight
captures you could go Queen captures
Queen captures Bishop captures and now
your knight is attacked you have to
defend it and after all is said and done
white just gonna develop and like we
said that the bishop already guards the
b2 pawn so that's not a problem white is
just up a clean pawn so after Bishop to
c5
you can go b6 so Bishop to e6 but what's
the idea you're still losing the d5 pawn
yes that's true but you are getting the
b2 pawn so this was Adams plan we have
Knight captures Bishop capture son b2
now and just rook a to d1 Adams gave up
his central pawn for the b2 pawn while
doing this he created three pawn islands
in the dings camp while he himself has
two point islands and with equal
material he will he will definitely want
to use this but we have rush of
characters on d5 Bishop captures and now
Queen to g5 he offers a queen trade and
ding obliges as ding now has the bishop
pair and he will well he will use them
you could go f4 just avoid the trade of
Queens after Queen h5 just go by three
it's one possibility but then black also
has a lot of pressure against your king
so it would be maybe some what to do
double ditched not if it was possible
dink would surely go for it to dink is
not afraid of you know extremely
aggressive lines of risky play he he
always you know tries to create
fireworks on the board and which is
pretty amazing considering how how few
games he actually loses but okay we have
a queen to g5 offering a queen trade
ding obliges Queen captures H captures
and now c4 c4 is a very important move
as well on c2 it's a backwards pawn very
weak pawn we have C 4 here preparing to
move the dark square bishop and for
example if the bishop
moves to at the e3 you will be able to
pull this pawn to c5 and and see [ __ ]
this pawn will be very strong so here we
have look a to c8 aligning the rook with
the bishop and the pawn here on c4 first
h3 removing the defender of the e3
square so the bishop can now retreat the
e3 we have Knight to f6 and now just
Bishop to e3
getting out of the way preparing c5 also
attacking the g5 pawn and here at black
finds a very nice idea
g4 it's it's important to say that while
the material is equal dink still has
three point islands while Adams has two
point islands but on the other hand
Adams has a GG pond so he wants to get
rid of at least one of his double points
g4 now you could push h4 but that way
black would have a very strong Jeep on
here and also I would be able to give up
the other double spawn so you wouldn't
really be doing anything so just push up
to g2 and okay pawn captures special
captures we have roped the c7 getting
out of the way as the rope was under
attack and c8 and now King to g2 with
Knights the e5 attacking the c4 pawn
twice and now well the well-prepared
move c5 King to g7 improving the
position of the king and now bush of to
f4 pinning the night rook cita east 7
and now just a rook to d2 attacking the
bishop here you have to move it Bishop
to e3 and now we have rook to be for the
idea is rook to a4 you want to attack
the bishop and the a7 point so at least
you're gonna win a pawn Adams goes
Knight to c6 attack stroke while also
already you know defends the a7 pawn we
have group 2a for attacks the Bishop of
Bishop to b4 the be for square is now
also guarded by the night and now Bishop
to d6 and now this Bishop finds an
excellent outpost
it's really you you really control a lot
of squares here all of these squares are
covered by by dings bishops so you do
have to move the rope we have looked at
eetu and now well there's also pressure
against the White King if this night can
somehow let's say in could be included
in the attack against the f2 pond and
maybe this rook will be stuck here
guarding the
two point for a very long time first we
have Knights to d4 yeah you have you
have to decide what to do here
we have Knights to d4 sorry right night
to d4 I with the idea of attacking the
rockin e2 but also attacking the the
defender of the bishop on before so the
idea is you capture here and then you're
just gonna win a piece so Adams captures
we have Knight captures on d4 rook
captures on b4 now and now you could go
for Knight to c6 just go back and give
up upon for a pawn for example rook
captures rook captures but then just
King G one rookies a bishop is coming to
g2 and well this past pawn will be
extremely strong and well it will be
very hard to stop it so after this rook
captures and before black again finds an
active plan night to see two attacks the
rook here and also threatens to win the
exchange with the Knights the e3 check
as the F do pawn is pinned
but King doesn't mind he use of the
exchange
we have rook after Sun b2 now nice to e3
check we have King to f3 attacks the
rook Knight captures rook on f1 now the
rook again defends the rook so you
cannot to capture it
we have Bishop captures on f1 attacking
the rook and now just rook to c2 and
here Bishop to b5 an excellent move
you're preparing c6 wild attacking the
rook so black has to deal with this we
have looked at a six now preventing the
immediate c6 because you would lose a
bishop here but then white just plays
rook captures an a7 now Dean has to to
pass pawns but he's still down the
exchange but you know it's easier to be
down the exchange we have when you have
the bishop pair because the bishop pair
is just is extremely powerful tool if
you use it properly Knight to e4 now
with ideas of Knight g5 check if DF to
point is somehow defended but okay you
cannot defend the NDF to pawn here so
the real threat is rook captures on f2
but also this rook can come to f6 with
check you can pick up this point with
this rook a lot of ideas here for black
and here it's a it's a really double
dutch position if you you know if you
make a mistake here you can easily even
you know lose this game with white so
there is no like crushing move here or
anything but just feel free to pause the
video here and how would you continue
this position would white it's you know
a very nice exercise if you will I'll
give you a couple of seconds well for
those of you who play who found the move
ding played you are you know just just
an amazing player there's no other way
to put it and for those of you who are
just interested in enjoying the show
being played Bishop to d7 this is
something you had to calculate because
the rook captures an f2 is unstoppable
so what happens next is is what matters
rook captures an f2 was played with to
check with King to e3 now of course the
threat is to capture the rook so what do
you play here you can't really move the
knight as both this rook and this rook
will be under attack you can't give up
back give back the exchange just any way
for example if you Knight captures with
check you'll get Bishop characters here
and then after loop to f6 you will get
Bishop to d7 after Knight moves Knight
a5 check you'll get Bishop captures and
after G captures over captures for that
matter you will have this position where
black has either a doubled pawn or if
you capture with the room then the pawn
can start advancing immediately material
just have a winning position for white
so after King to e3 we have looked after
f6 Adams decides to give back the
exchange this way so Bishop captures we
have rook captures and now Bishop to c7
you have to give back this pawn but you
will keep your past a for a pond with
Knight captures on c5 with check a
discover check from the rook King to d4
and now just Knights the a6 hoping to
win the Bishop Bishop to e5 check came
to f8 and now a3 taking away the be
Foursquare from the Black Knight King to
g8 you also want to you know increase
the activity of the black King and now
King d5 with nice to see 5 Adam finds a
way to activate the knight of course now
if you capture you lose the bishop so
first just a four key you keep on
pushing your path bone as of course Pass
bones must be pushed
we have Knights to d7 with a double
attack against the bishop and Bishop to
c7
Knight to f6 check by Adams King to c4
and not rook to c6 with check King King
King b5 and now rook to c2 and here just
a 5
so here the material is still equal on
the board it's a bishop against tonight
but dink has already has a passed pawn
on a 5 and his King is much more active
than Adams King King 37 with Bishop to
e5 now I discovered to check we have
kinked back to e6 you have to defend the
night and now rook the c7 hoping to
trade rooks if you trade rooks it in of
course the past pawn is winning we
looked to 18 now putting a look behind a
passport either you should do it even if
it's your pawn or her if it's your
opponent's pawn but now Dean just plays
Bishop captures an F on f6 it was
important to realize that now the the
while the piece are exchanged White has
a huge advantage King captures on f6 and
now a6
we look to be to check by Adams King to
c6 now rook back to a 2 and not a7 and
here we have a king to g5 going for the
g3 pawn we have rook captures on f7 King
g4 and now rook to g7 hoping to win this
pawn as well
we have g5 and here dink played King to
b7 and it was in this position that
Michael Adams resigned to the game and
an excellent victory on move 59 for
China board 1 Dingley Ren and well well
if you resign you're gonna lose the game
how are you gonna lose it well after a
few checks let's say we'll be to check
you have to move King c7 look-see you
check you can move King bit and after
another check you'll just block this
check with the rook now of course if you
exchange rooks then the pawn Queens and
if you just go rook back to it to now it
now would be a good way I decided to
show this here you could make a mistake
if you just queen and you think this is
not winning it's not because after black
captures this pawn now black will just
move the king and he will push this
point you will have to give up your look
for the pawn and it will be a draw so
before queening the point you have to
play rook to b3 you just guard the pawn
and of course it's winning whatever
black plays doesn't really matter engage
three now you will Queen the pawn and
after captures captures your
his defendant doesn't really matter what
black plays your King has all the time
in the world to reach this pawn win it
and well Bush pushed heard the other
pawn to victory sure
after King to be seven my Clarence
resigned and an excellent victory for
ding Lehrer and we already shown the
results of the sorry not that not that
of the penultimate round so here it is
China with this victory on four points
Russia is still leading after the
penultimate round so here as we are as
you are watching this video China India
and Russia are battling it out in the
final round Russia cannot lose first
place but it will still be a very
interesting match sure there we have it
a few announcements before you know we
end the video tomorrow 6 6 p.m. Central
European Time we will start well not our
first but first in a longtime
subscribers tournament it will be it
will be one maybe maybe an hour maybe an
hour and a half I still haven't decided
I have some other things to do tomorrow
so will I will keep you informed
you know I will publish it on my Twitter
page Facebook page wherever wherever you
you know also follow me aside from
YouTube so you will be well informed so
that's basically it great victory for
ding livin I would like to thank camera
me Ramadi Chris Picard Trevor Friesen
Ajit Govind and Esmeralda Hermitage for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos see her
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
hopefully with more interesting content
we will check out at least one game from
the ultimate round or the final round of
the 2009 teen ball team championship
check up on your suggestions and then
before I guess we're starting the next
week's tournament is grant HS classic
before that we are continuing the
Capablanca saga so you know don't be
afraid we are getting back to that and
for the for the end of the video another
glimpse at this very nice photo photo of
Sasha there you have it thank you all
and I will see you soon